la ville de montréal investit un million
de dollars dans la création d'un office
de la gastronomie ce projet doit
favoriser le rayonnement des chefs et
des artisans à l'international et vise à
assurer la relève dans le milieu ce
projet s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un
projet de relance justement de
l'économie montréalaise de 25 millions
de dollars et le car de l'argent est
consacrée au secteur de la restauration
la restauration qui fait face à des
défis de taille en ce moment on en parle
avec francine brûlé qui est présidente
des restaurants les enfants terribles
présent dans la grande région de
montréal à magog également on soit
madame brûlé mention monsieur fillion
bon alors comment se passe votre était
est ce que la clientèle est au rendez
vous depuis corner ouvert à la bonne
nouvelle c'est que la clientèle est au
rendez vous et je dois dire qu'en plus
d'être au rendez vous elle est
généreuse avec nous les patientes avec
nous parce que je pense que les clients
savent toutes les difficultés qu'on a
cet été avec le personnel et ils sont
patients
oui avec le grand manque de personnel
c'est pas léger comme manque de
personnel on manque de personnel on sait
pas où ils sont les
puisqu'ils sont tous les employés c'est
incroyable c'est vraiment ce qu'est ce
que j'ai fait qu'est ce que vous avez
fait pour composer avec ça madame brûlé
cet été dans les derniers mois
chaque restaurant ouvert à des heures
des jours différents chacun dit on on a
des dizaines la situation le nombre
d'employés ont décidé en outre quel jour
combien jour combien d'heures on a aussi
fonctionné à menu réduit pendant une
bonne partie de l'été dans certains cas
ou encore parce qu'on n'a pas assez de
personnel en cuisine pour être capables
de combler la demande en salle les ceux
qui sont venus travailler on était
vraiment extraordinaire à faire beaucoup
d'heures à des affaires des deux puits a
vraiment donné pour satisfaire
est ce que je dis est ce que vous avez
même augmenter les salaires ou les prix
des menus
assez incroyable on a tout augmente et
on n'a pas le choix les denrées à otepää
partant tout augmente et se regarde
juste le saumon c'est presque 10 %
d'augmentation lui le pratiquement 50%
d'augmentation
on a énormément de 2 d'augmentation sur
tous nos produits en plus beaucoup de
ruptures on a énormément de rupture
alors c'est tout seul qu'il faut des
fois on dit sur les médias sociaux les
clients savent pas de bon sens il y
avait même pas son nom il y en a pas d
pas capables d'en avoir on fait le tour
on a quelqu'un qui crée que ça de tous
deux pour trouver des produits qui
manquent de tout et quand même est
exceptionnel et puis on a augmenté aussi
les salaires le prince charles et les
gens pour revenir nous ont demandé des
augmentations et puis on ne parle que de
ça et là en plus de l'enjeu de la main
d'oeuvre le gouvernement va donner les
détails de son passeport vaccinale
demain
vous devrez vous restaurateurs vous
assurer que les gens ont leurs
passeports occitane mais scanner bien
sûr on aura des détails demain mais vous
vous entrevoyez sort commun
écoutez nous depuis le début monsieur
fillion on en fait on irait il ya j'ai
pas les compétences pour juger toutes
les décisions que le gouvernement prend
alors on a pris la route des transilien
moi je suis content des vaccins j'ai
trimé de vaccin parce que c'est une
situation qui est mondial et il faut
qu'on fasse tous quelque chose pour
arriver arrêter d'en parler si le
gouvernement me dit que je suis obligé
de faire ça écoutez je peux pas aller
contre la loi je vais faire ce qu'il
faut et j'espère y est d'expliquer le
but qu'on peut à nos clients que on n'a
pas le choix c'est ça il faut qu'ils
nous montrent la preuve je dirais que
dalle clientèle un grande grande
majorité ont été vaccinées deux fois
parce qu'on il vient dans leur part
d'avec ses deux fois je peux donner mecs
ne veut pas bref on a une clientèle je
pense qui est assez vite signer on veut
le voir plus à partir du 1er septembre
c'est là qu'on va voir que je pense aux
gens pommade certaine il ya des gens qui
vont
sur le but et à cette demande là et on
va devoir
je les fabrique
écoutez qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse et c'est comme une lourde il faut
travailler avec un masque faisait 40
degrés 45 degrés dans le restaurant
cette semaine ils ont dit la cuisine de
l'enlever dehors ils peuvent lire
l'intérieur dont alors les employés ont
gardé leur masse est-ce qu'ils avaient
du mal à l'aise ils ont été levés
quelque chose s'est il s'est plongé il
dit règlement gelé suit les règles mais
moi j'ai pris cette décision de l'ofj
lui bon c'est bien considérez vous que
vous avez besoin encore de l'aide
gouvernementale est de loyer subvention
salariale par exemple
écouter c'est ce que le dernier moins de
un bon mois parce que on a eu des
terrasses ont eu des terrasses que c'est
assez exceptionnel mais je suis très
inquiète aussi tous que les terrains ont
fermé qui va commencer à faire froid les
gens
viennent pas abondamment à l'intérieur
ils viennent à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur ils veulent garder leur
calme alors je suis inquiet si on est
capable d'arriver avec les augmentations
de salaires qu'on me donnait là les
subventions qui seront plus au rendez
vous je ne sais pas certaines commencent
à voir comment je me posais la question
on fait des riches et aujourd'hui on
était qui et de sa joie vous eh bien on
va continuer de vous suivre de toute
façon certainement bonne chance pour la
suite merci madame brûlé merci monsieur
villach en soirée au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit